six heures de direct que hier soir sur
toutes les grandes chaînes de télévision
françaises pour récolter des fonds en
faveur de la lutte contre le sida un
événement marqué par l'émotion mais
aussi par la passion de certains
intervenants
j'imagine le sens de la vie il est là
dans ce qu'on peut partager avec mes
amis j'ai pu aucune défense immunitaire
g0 t4 et je me permets jose vivre et
j'irai le seul risque que je prends
aujourd'hui c'est le risque de vivre et
2 et encore aînés l'espoir de patricia
part de la maladie et souffrance un
moment fort de la soirée du sidaction
près de six heures d'émission pour
tenter d'enrayer la progression du fléau
de rester debout depuis que cette
émission a commencé là maintenant à
peine dix minutes cinquante personnes
dans le monde ont été contaminées par le
virus du sida
la collecte doit durer tout l'été il
faudra donc attendre plusieurs semaines
pour disposer des premiers résultats
dans tous les cas cette deuxième édition
restera marquée par l'intervention des
militants d'act-up dénonçant les
expulsions d'étrangers atteints du sida
ias un avion pour le zaïre mardi son
départ lady avec à la préfecture elle
peut se faire expulser mardi est la
gamma qui est malade qui vit
actuellement malade dans un hôpital
français c'est quoi c'est un pays de
merde
aujourd'hui le président d'act up
affirme qu'il n'avait rien prémédité
sans renier ses propos il plaide le coup
de sang j'en pouvais plus j'étais je
voyais ces images vous voyez tout ce
côté émotionnel à moyens la famille les
enfants et je pensais quand même au à
tous les militants d'act up qui était
mort depuis le printemps précédent
sidaction devant un public quelque peu
chahuté le nom de la fin restera à
michel boujenah qui rappelle l'objectif
de la soirée
ça parle il faut que les gens se
disputent mais ce soir il ya une chose
qui est importante c'est envoyer de
l'argent c'est se battre pour que les
gens donnent de l'argent mais plutôt 300
millions de francs